d'un côté la tour eiffel à paris de
l'autre la porte de brandebourg à berlin
deux monuments europe et emblématique
redécorée aux couleurs de l'ukraine un
symbole mais rien de plus à berlin les
dirigeants français et allemand ont
réitéré leur soutien l'ukraine en guerre
contre la russie mais emmanuel macron a
douché les espoirs de kiev
quant à une éventuelle adhésion rapide
de l'ukraine à l'union européenne nous
savons tous que compte tenu de nos
standards et de ces critères il faudra
des années vraisemblablement des
décennies pour que l'ukraine puisse
vraiment rejoindre l'union européenne
officiellement cinq pays sont
actuellement dans l'antichambre de
l'union mais à l'image de la turquie
candidate depuis 23 ans l'attend peut
être très longue pour l'expliquer il y a
des différends d'ordre politique comme
le respect des valeurs démocratiques
mais aussi les critères économiques
strictes à respecter
d'où la proposition du président
français de créer une communauté
politique européenne une sorte
d'alliance de nation porté
essentiellement sur la politique et la
sécurité
il s'agit d'une proposition très
intéressante pour relever le grand défi
auquel nous sommes confrontés nous
faisons avancer le processus
d'intégration permanente de l'union
européenne on se parle nous voulons tous
deux une union européenne forte et
souveraine des pays comme l'ukraine
pourrait faire partie de cette nouvelle
communauté
mais kiev s'accroche à sa candidature à
l'union européenne
volodymyr zelensky l'a rappelé hier soir
où nous espérons recevoir une réponse
positive concernant l'acquisition du
statut de candidat à l'union européenne
de notre pays en juin le résultat reste
incertain car le statut de candidat
officiel doit être approuvée à
l'unanimité par les 27 états membres de
l'union